hi steve kaufman here bonjour you see
steve kaufman
today i'm going to talk about french
esco le francais et difficile i'm going
to speak initially in english and then
in french remember if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe click on the
bell for notifications and if you follow
me on a podcast please leave a comment
so
french french has things that makes it
easy to learn and things that makes it
difficult to learn
the biggest sort of factor that would
make uh french easy
is that it shares a lot of vocabulary
with english
and english is very widely spoken not
only in english-speaking countries but
by people all around the world
uh i don't know statistically i think
something like 60 of words in english
are of french origin or at least of
latin
based language origin but most of that
comes from french from the time of the
norman
french invasion of britain in 1066.
so if there are so many common words i
mean the biggest obstacle to learning a
language
is vocabulary
and
when you listen to the french portion of
this video
you will see that
most of the words are identifiable as
words that we use in english
and
the french portion of this video will be
made available
uh in link as a lesson even though i'm
not a native speaker
so that you can look up words and
phrases and learn them so the big
advantage therefore that english
speakers have in learning french is
vocabulary i can tell you as someone who
has learned languages where there is
little or no vocabulary common to
languages that i know it's a lot more
difficult and even though there are some
so-called false friends
the similarity in vocabulary is an
enormous advantage
sometimes we don't recognize
that these words are
the same or similar to english words
because they are spelt differently
for example wherever in french they use
an
an axon accent you know the a goo and or
the c of conflicts very often that hides
an s so a to j is like study
a call is school
oat is host or hotel is hostile so that
if you
put an s in where you see those accents
you will find it easier to recognize
those words as being similar to
english words
so that's the good news
what makes things a little more
difficult is that french spelling
is
not
obvious it's not obvious that
e-a-u-l-t
is o
um
you know even the sound o can be as in
mo meaning word
or bo b-e-a-u
mo is written m-o-t
mo plurals m-o-t-s and you don't hear
the s
bo
b-e-a-u is bo if it's plural you put an
x on it you still don't hear the x
unless there's a liaison so
that's just touching on the surface of
the difficulties with french spelling
not obvious to an english speaker but
then spelling in english isn't obvious
to non-english speakers so this is
something that we have to get used to
and it is an element that makes french
somewhat more difficult the only
solution is to do a lot of reading
and listening and getting used to how
words that are written a certain way are
pronounced
spelling therefore is a problem
i consider the issues of pronunciation
and comprehension related
some people find french difficult to
understand because of the nasal sounds
and because of the liaison so first of
all the nasal sounds the uh
oh
[Music]
don't exist in english and
it's very easy to get them wrong when we
speak
and sometimes to not understand well
when we hear them in different contexts
uh
another issue that affects comprehension
is the liaison where very often the
consonant of the previous word
almost seems like the initial consonant
in the next word
and therefore we don't notice what we're
listening to if you hear like
contamina is it tamwa or khan
tamwa if it's ca all by itself it's gone
when it's followed by a vowel in the
next
word it becomes contamina and it's as if
the consonant has all of a sudden been
attached to
the
succeeding word so those are things
again that we can read explanations of
but until we train our brain through a
lot of listening it's difficult another
difficulty in french is gender and it's
not obvious
whereas say in spanish words that end in
o tend in most cases to be masculine
words that end in a tend in most cases
to be feminine
in french it's less obvious
and i'll go give you some examples in
the french portion of this video
so gender is an issue so le and la
plural is an issue
but all of these things and and i should
finish by saying verbs can be difficult
with the many different conjugations a
variety of tenses
um
nowadays of course with uh conjugating
dictionaries such as we use at link it's
easy every time you see a verb to look
it up see which
form of the verb that is in the
conjugation table
and every time you do that you kind of
scan the conjugation table itself and it
sort of helps you notice what's
happening but in the end you simply have
to spend a lot of time with the language
in the french video i will uh recommend
a song that you can listen to to work on
your pronunciation
uh because this song includes many of
the sounds that i think are crucial to
french such as the uh sound uh that is
an e without an accent uh when it's
pronounced and irwin is not pronounced
and it's called
cheval blanc so it's
but can also be
so the uh sometimes disappears uh is
sometimes pronounced at the end of the
word sometimes not pronounced but i
think having a sense of the use of the
uh this is my personal theory is very
helpful
in getting
the feel of french and being able to
pronounce french and i very much
recommend you listen to this
uh song by george brassence